it was a trial that captivated a nation
lorena bobbitt lorena bobbitt lorena
bobbitt took a knife cut off her husband
Pina but what does lorena bobbitt have
to do with this thing let's take a step
back this is the bobbitt worm it's a
species of eunice unit Yoon I see thanks
Terry you're most welcome that's dr.
Terry Gosselin ER ter ry g he's a senior
curator at the California Academy of
Sciences and I do research on coral
reefs around the world he's the one who
gave the bobbitt war of its name they go
way back in 1992 I went to the
Philippines and I saw my first Bobbitt
work to actually see it in action was
really one of the most amazing things
I've seen this thing has nope nope nope
written all over it
I'm sorry what from it spiked glowing
exoskeleton and the body is very
iridescent shiny too it's spring-loaded
jaws they just spring shut like a bear
trap and his unique predatory style when
it sees a fish it pops more and more out
of the water and then grabs the fish and
takes it back into the sand what anyway
after years of research in the
indo-pacific dr. garner published this
book coral reef animals of the Indo
Pacific when it came time to name the
worm
dr. Gosselaar found an unlikely source
of inspiration there was this guy named
John Wayne Bobbitt who had cheated on
his wife and while he was sleeping one
night she cut off his penis and threw it
in a field nearby wait what and in the
worm basically the the ability to use as
massive jaws to cut the spinal cord of a
fish was something that reminded me of
what Lorena Bobbitt did to her husband
so there you have it
something else to keep you everything
I've never had nightmares about it
whatever dr. Terry